nous sommes très heureux de vous
annoncer l'arrivée de liberté gym au
portugal à porto avec un master fund
tous ceux qui l'ont croisé disent avoir
été charmé par son bagout et forcément
aussi par sa stature patrick boyen aussi
un mystère fitness dans sa jeunesse
aujourd'hui patron d'une marque de
salles de sport établi sur tout le
territoire national
une galaxie parfaitement organisés
jusqu'à ce qu'un artisan tire la
sonnette d'alarmé
ce peintre en bâtiment à travailler pour
patrick boyen des chantiers rendus dans
les temps mais l'argent lui n'est jamais
arrivé on a commencé vraiment à prendre
peur et disons à à comprendre la
supercherie
quand on a quand on a menacé d'arrêter
de quitter le chantier
faute d'être d'être réglé
avec ces menaces on a réussi à avoir un
seul gros règlement patrick boyen a été
arrêté la semaine dernière à l'aéroport
charles de gaulle
la justice le soupçonne de blanchiment
de fraude fiscale et d'avoir organisé
son insolvabilité lui qui gère
directement une dizaine de salles de
sport n'a quasiment pas de compte
bancaire en france
l'artisan que nous avons rencontrés ne
lâche rien il a failli mettre la clé
sous la porte
si une entreprise déposer le bilan la
créance cette année avec la société moi
je souhaitais vraiment maintenir notre
créance est tout faire pour la pour la
recouvrer puisque c'est mon personnel
qui a travaillé c'est lui qui allait qui
s'est sacrifié aujourd'hui patrick boyen
avait rendez-vous avec la justice mais
pour une autre affaire vieille de dix
ans un élu réseau de centres
d'amincissement pour certains un galop
d'essai avant liberty gym il ya dix
sociétés à l'île maurice et des sociétés
à cardiff en angleterre il ya des
comptes au luxembourg bon tout ça est
très opaque et monsieur moyen apparaît
officiellement de rien la notion
d'insolvabilité dans un
un pays comme le nôtre est compliqué
parce que on est en europe avoir des
comptes bancaires au luxembourg en
angleterre ou avoir une société en
espagne c'est conforme au droit européen
dans la sphère liberty gym le montant de
la fraude reste inconnu entre des
centaines de milliers d'euros selon la
justice et plusieurs millions d'euros